So we have seen that with assertions we can ensure that objects
are in a sane state all the time.
You can imagine that this would be most useful for large, complex data structures.
That is, structures with lots and lots of invariance that need to be maintained
or that could possibly be violated due to programming errors.
Let me illustrate this with one of the most devilish data structures ever invented,
which is a Red-Black tree.
Here's an example of a Red-Black tree.
A Red-Black tree is a data structure to represent associative arrays
also known as mappings.
If I want to search an element in a Red-Black tree,
I can do so in an almost logarithmic time.
And I do so as in all search trees by checking whether the element
I'm searching for is smaller or larger than the element I'm looking at.
Suppose I want to check whether the number 22 is in my Red-Black tree:
I start at the root, which is 13, I'm looking for 22, which is larger than 13,
so I go along the right branch, 22 is larger than 17, so again I go along the right branch,
22 is smaller than 25 so now I go along the left branch,
until I'll end up exactly in the element I was searching for.
Red-Black trees do not only guarantee search in logarithmic time
but also insertion and also deletion, which makes them a real nice choice
for all sorts of search operations.
But they also are very, very difficult to debug.
The reason they're difficult to debug is they do have a number of properties
that must be maintained at all times.
To start with, they always must be trees. You can't have any cycle in it.
A black node must have red children, and a red node must have black children.
The number of elements in the subtrees should be fairly equal
with respect to the number of black nodes, and if some element points to a child
the child maintains a pointer then this should point back to the exact same parent.
So search in Red-Black tree is easy but insertion and removal are really complicated.
To get an idea just how complicated they are, let's take a look on Wikipedia
what they wrote about Red-Black trees.
So this is the Wikipedia page on Red-Black trees.
Here's the insertion. These are two helper functions, grandparent and uncle.
Now we go to 1, 2, 3 different cases all with individual code that needs to be handled.
Here's case number 4, and here's case number 5.
Removal is even more complicated. This is the formal description.
We need a helper function called the sibling.
Here's a helper function to delete one child, which is easy.
And now come all the special cases: case 1, case 2, case 3, case 4, case 5, and case 6.
And of course, you can imagine how easy it is to make mistakes in any of these cases.
It would have some pointer pointing to the wrong node,
and again it would easily create lots and lots of time bombs
which is why we normally do not implement Red-Black trees
but we rather rely on Red-Black trees as implemented in some library.
However, if you were to implement a Red-Black tree,
say part of a programming exercise for instance, it's cool.
Or you're working on something that's similar to a Red-Black tree,
but which doesn't have yet its page in the Wikipedia,
then you really need to make sure that you don't screw up things
and that you don't create a time bomb in here.
If you work on a data structure as complex as this,
the very first thing you need to write in an invariant checker.